hello everyone thanks for being here
today
at this track so before diving in the
wondrous world of polyfills i'd like to
take some time to introduce myself i'm
leaving
as you can see there three times it's a
greek name
uh i live in greece i'm a front-end
developer
i love css and javascript but don't
worry i'm not going to start singing now
these are the places you can find me on
the web
so many people know me from for my css
research and they were asking me
yesterday
if it's going to be a talk about css and
i was like
dude it's a javascript conference it's
i'm not going to speak about css
so no it's not about css polyfills
people and polyfills are to css about
what the fork is to sushi
you can use it to eat sushi but it's not
really a very good idea
and it's not meant for that purpose so
what are polyfills
boyfriends is a term coined by remy
sharp
last year but it caught up really
quickly
and it actually comes from this product
on the cover that's a uk product
and it's used in the uk to cover up
holes and gaps in
cracks and walls and he thought that
it's a proper term for describing what
polyfills do in a browser
because that's essentially what they do
they cover up holes and gaps in browser
support
his official definition for that
was that a polyfill is
a piece of code or plugin for example
chrome frame could be considered a kind
of polyfill
that provides the technology that you
the developer expect the browser to
provide natively
or as paul irish put it it's a shame
that mimics a future api
by providing fallback functionality to
all the browsers
so if that sounds a bit unclear
i'm pretty sure almost all of you have
done this thing
at some point this is three lines of
code
or five depending on how you count them
but they essentially have all the
elements of a good polyfill
they have feature they they firstly
detect if the feature is present
is a stream available in strengths and
if it's not
they go ahead and implement the feature
and just
this is a very simple feature so one
line is enough
and then after that polyfill is included
the end developer can use it
as if it was provided natively and they
can do
that thing without being aware that the
polyfill actually exists
and that's one of the best advantages of
polyfills
you don't have to learn a new api for
example
jquery is a script that helps us
do some tasks that in which support is a
bit flaky for example
some ie old ie uses a touch event
uh modern browsers use event listener
and jquery covers up this
uh inconsistency but you before using
it you have to learn a new api it has a
whole documentation which you have to
learn before you're able to take
advantage of it
polyfills are not that jquery is not a
polyfill it's an api wrapper
with polyfills you don't need to learn
anything new just a spec
and then after a polyfill is included
you can move on use the spec
as if that functionality was provided
natively and after some years pass
you can just remove the polyfill and
your code still works there's no
dependency on the polyfill
it's just there to bridge the gap
between today
and the specs because sometimes we have
amazing
innovative specs that just aren't
supported yet and we want to use them
that's what polyfills are for so how can
you make your own polyfill
there's like ways we saw in that very
simple example of trim
there are three basic steps the first
step
is feature detection is this feature
already present
because if it is we don't need to do
anything we just use the native
implementation
if the native implementation is buggy
and we need to fix it somehow that's not
really a polyfill
if it's not present we go to the second
step
which is implementation this is the most
clever part most tricky part where you
actually have to think
of a way to emulate the functionality
that's missing
in some cases it's simple like in the
new eczmascript
methods for strings and rays these are
the simplest polyfills
in some cases it's very tricky like for
example in css boyfields these are the
the hardest of all and after you've done
you're done with your code
and you've implemented the feature the
third part is
distribution you have your amazing code
you're proud of it
but other people need to be able to find
it and use it
and you you need to to publish it
somewhere
and in format that's easy for them to
use
and you need to actually let people know
by including it
in the different lists of polyfills that
are available
so let's talk a bit about the first part
that's feature detection
i think this is one of the most
important parts of polyfills
because if you do that right you save on
lots of performance if
if you the feature is already present
and you move ahead and
implement it again that's a waste you
don't need
that waste you need to actually rely on
the feature if it is there
so the two main strategies we use
when uh feature detecting are a
check if something exists this is the
simplest
uh feature detection method you just
check if an api is there if a property
is there if a function is there
and if it is you assume that the feature
is present
this is much better for performance
because you just check existence of a
property
and it's much much simpler code usually
it's just one line
but sometimes it doesn't work sometimes
there are false positives or sometimes
it's just not possible to detect a
feature by detecting
uh if something exists which brings us
to the second
core idea trying something and then
trying to check if it worked that's much
more reliable
because you actually check the
functionality you don't assume that just
because it's there it works
but it's also much more verbose code
uh it's much bigger and it's much slower
than just checking if something is there
but sometimes it's the only way
and the third method is a combination of
the previous two
you first try something and then you
check did it actually work
was something created so let's try and
see how
you we can detect a few common
uh css html and javascript features
that we commonly need the first
way which uses the which uses the first
core idea checking if something exists
is checking about javascript api support
like for example is local storage on
window is geolocation in the navigator
object
or it's quite a selector and document
as you can see that's really easy really
small
we just use one line of code for
every api checking if css properties are
supported is
about as straightforward we just create
a dummy element
and we check if the property is in the
style object
in actual cases you shouldn't create a
new element every time
i'm just creating a new element here
just to make it simpler but
in actual use cases you should cache it
because it's not really a good idea to
just create one
every time this function is called or
maybe you should also cache the results
because if it's supported it will always
be supported
another method of checking whether css
properties
are supported is by using the second
core idea which is especially useful
if you want to check multiple versions
of that property like
multiple prefixes so you can still
follow the previous method but you would
need to camel case your property
and you will need to create two common
case versions of your property
because for example border radius that's
without a prefix is common case to board
the radius without
and the first b is lowercase most border
radius is common cased with a capital
m and then the b is also uppercase
so in this method we iterate over all
the prefixes
we get the prefixed version of the
property
and then we set the css text of the
dummy element
to a declaration that uses that property
and because in here it is supported by
every css property it should get
accepted if the property is supported
it should accept inherit so then we try
to get the value
of that property and if there's a value
we return
that version of the property because we
know that property is supported
if none of these prefix properties are
supported
then in this case we return undefined in
if that function was more correct it
should return null
checking css values requires a bit of a
test
there's nothing we can check existence
for so we actually need
to apply the property we just choose any
rgba value it would work
and actually that method is not just for
rgba it applies for any kind of css
property for calc
for hsla for mozilla for element for the
element function anything
so you just choose one value that uses
this feature
and then you check was there an error uh
is there
did the property keep its value because
browsers just did
ditch anything in css that doesn't work
if you provide an invalid property it
gets dropped if you provide an invalid
value it gets dropped
so if it actually kept that value it
means it's supported
css selectors are also a bit tricky you
need to create a new style element
you just create a simple rule by using
that selector it's an empty rule it
doesn't need to create
it doesn't need to contain any
declarations just
the just as long as it uses the selector
and we append it to the document because
otherwise if it's just
in the dom hyperspace it won't uh it
won't get applied
so then we check uh is was it a rule
created
in this case i actually check if there's
a first css rule you could just check
the length of css rules
it's the same thing and we clean up
after all cells but by removing the
element
we don't need we don't want to leave it
in the document and mess up with the end
user's code
and we return the result if it was there
or not
detecting html elements is really hard
to do in a generic way
this could be a very optimistic thought
because if you read the dom
specification
it says that every element that's not
supported should inherit from the
html unknown element interface however
browsers
aren't expected to expose these
interfaces
it's not required as long as they use
them internally and also
some browsers don't even follow the spec
and they don't use that at all
for in some browsers it didn't have
unknown elements inherit from the html
element interface
it's really inconsistent so we can't do
that
it's it's nice but it won't work
so what we have to do instead
is check for known properties or known
methods are they present in a new
instance
of the element so
it's a bit hacky because we don't know
if they actually work
but it it gets it gets the job done it
works
it does what we do in most cases
so for example if we want to check
canvas support we check if the get
context method is there if we want to
check if video is supported we check the
play method if
if we wanted to be a bit more accurate
we could actually check if it's a
function and not just the property
html attributes are usually pretty
straightforward of course there are
caveats to that which
we'll see afterwards but in the general
case
you just assign uh you just check if
the the getter is present because
browsers uh assign a getter to every
attribute that they support if they
support the placeholder attribute on
inputs they also make
a placeholder gather and setter or if
they support multiple
file inputs they create a multiple
accessor
so we can just check it if that's
present it won't have a value so
checking
if input dot multiple has it through the
value won't work
but it will be present it will be
defined
and attribute values are about the same
as css
um values you just uh ch you just set
a proper that value and you check if
the browser actually kept it for example
in this case type is a supported
attribute
on inputs every browser supports it but
some values
aren't really supported for example the
number
type which is used to create a spinner
some browsers don't support that yet
like firefox or
ie so which we set the type to a number
and then we check if the browser
actually kept that
because if it doesn't it usually reverts
back to the text
value which is the default
for events we can do something similar
at least for events that have a
an accessor like on something for
example on mouse center
um we can set them to a very simple
function like return
nothing which does nothing and then
check was there a function actually
created
on that element if a function was
created it means it's supported
if nothing was if nothing is there it
means it's not
unfortunately there's no method there's
no way to detect
events like dom content loaded or
mutation events
we don't have a way for that we have to
detect something else that we know that
if it's present
these events are also present for
mutation events we can actually change
the dormancy
if they got uh if they got fired but
it's a bit
it's much more messy than that and
of course even the examples i showed
aren't always that simple
their browser bags and everything so
for example we checked if local storage
is supported by checking if it's present
on the window object
but in firefox 3.6 accessing local
storage throws an error so you also need
to
account for that or for example opera
doesn't support pointer events on html
elements but it still has them in the
style object
because it supports them in svg
so in we should before
actually deciding on a feature detection
code
we should really test in lots and lots
of browsers to see if it actually works
or maybe check the modernizer source to
see how they did it
because they need to test in many many
browsers
to develop their framework
and of course there are some features
that nobody can detect so far
the the undetectables
some features just you can't do anything
about them
even modernizer can't detect them
pointer events in opera used to be one
of them
because it had a false positive but now
some clever guy
whose name i forget actually came up
with the detection method
he's setting the property and then he's
checking the computed style to see if it
got applied
so now we can detect pointer events and
the code isn't that big
but there are many other properties that
and features that can't be detected
currently maybe you can think of a way
we we need that kind of thought uh we
need people to come up with new ways to
detect features
just because they're they are on that
list doesn't mean they can't be detected
it just means we're not clever enough
yet maybe you are
so after we're done with feature
detection
we're going to the interesting part
which is implementation
actually making the stuff work
the first rule i think every polyfill
should follow
is following the spec not that kind of
follow
actually being faithful to the spec and
doing
and fulfilling the expectations that
people have
there's no use if you're making a
polyfill that behaves in a way that you
think is better
but it's not what's expected it will be
inconsistent with native implementations
it will be inconsistent with what people
have learned it won't really be a
polyfill it will be an api wrapper
masquerading as a polyfill
but however as much as it's important to
follow the spec
you should also know when to stop
because you don't want
your polyfill to end up like this fine
lady
you don't want your polyfill to be
cluttered
for example i fell into that this trap
strap
when i created a polyfill for the html5
progress element
i wanted it to be as correct as possible
i wanted it to
respond to property changes and
attribute changes
and i wanted the css to be super
flexible
i wanted to make the best progress
polyfill
and i ended up with some code that's
200 lines just to support progress bars
who will who want to use 200 lines
just to be able to use the html5
progress bars
your polyfills need to be small so that
people
uh will want to include them
without introducing an overhead because
even when they're not executed because
the browser already supports the feature
usually they get downloaded and we don't
need
we don't want to add that much bandwidth
of course there are script loaders that
only conditionally load polyfills but
in the general case they're just
included along with any other script
a case that's quite tempting to go
overboard
is a polyfill for document head
how many of you actually have used
document head
it's the same thing as document body but
it refers to the head element
it's an html5 thing and it seems that
it's really easy to create a polyfill
for it
you just check if document head has a
value
and if it doesn't you just assign the
first head element
to it but however there's a big problem
in that
and i'm pretty sure some of you have
already started seeing it
if your document only has one frame
that's fine
it will work but if you have multiple
frames and you try to actually use that
in the other frame it won't you will get
a type error
it yes it breaks expectations but
what's the alternative what would you do
not to avoid this the only solution
is to hijack every frame in the document
monitor when frames get added and also
fix the document head for them as well
and sometimes windows get opened with
window open
so we should replace the window open
method and
and fix that too i mean it gets really
messy
we don't want that that's fine that
that two-line polyfill is what most
people want they don't want a huge
script that's super intrusive
and easy to break
just for document head after all instead
of doing that they'll just
assign the head element to a variable
and get it over with
the second rule i think most polyfills
should follow is
not being intrusive like i said
polyfills should
follow expectations and the expectations
aren't that
you hijack your horse document with a
relevant crap
try not to replace the target element
with another for example
even if you're super careful and you
copy all properties and all
attributes and everything at the very
least you'll wipe out
all event listeners and
it's really hard for the end user
to work with that also try not to
manipulate
unrelated elements like the body it
might be tempting to add a class to the
body
to use it in your css if your polyfill
comes with a css like html polyfills for
example
it might be tempting to add a class to
the body to
which corresponds to whether that
feature is supported or not
but you should try to find another way
to do it because
the the host document might actually
depend
on how many classes the body has
there might they might have a selector
in your in their css about the body not
having a class or if the body having
only one
class or something like that and that
will break and they'll be wondering why
did it break
and they'll find out it's your poly film
they won't like it much
adding extra elements sometimes is
inevitable but you should try to be as
conservative as possible
for example if you're making an html
polyfill try to take advantage of the
pseudo elements instead of
adding new elements to the dom that
break existing selectors
that are already in the host document
for example especially now
with css3 selectors we have
many css rules that depend on the play
on the place an element has in the
document
on its index among its siblings and how
many elements
something has so you're breaking this
if you add extra elements try to avoid
it
also manipulating existing attributes is
sometimes the only way but
try to avoid that too like for example
going through the elements you care
about and
changing their ideas or adding ideas or
stuff like that
so you have to do it sometimes but
it it breaks expectations for the host
document so try to avoid it
i guess i don't need to tell you that
that you should
try not to pollute the global namespace
you probably already know it but i had
to
to add it and also that's quite obvious
too but
sometimes it breaks try not what leaky
css like for example
you should name space your css to only
apply to what you add
to what you target don't add css like
for example
an element selector that would leak in
other elements
and not just to your the target of your
polyfill
and of course all these are just
guidelines rules of thumb
in most cases you will need to break at
least one of them
in most polyfills at least in most html
polyfills
but just try to only do them if you
really really have to
also remember when we said at the
beginning that
one of the biggest advantages of
polyfills is that
they you will be able to remove them
after a certain point maybe after some
months maybe after some years
when support gets uh better and you
don't need that anymore because the
browsers that don't support that feature
are really old and nobody uses them
anymore so you don't want the overhead
so you're you'll you should be able to
remove that polyfill and your
your code still works without the
polyfill in in browsers that support
this feature
so you shouldn't require from the end
user of your polyfill
to do stuff like this feature detection
belongs in your polyfill
gathering on the elements and fixing
them also
depends on your polyfill belongs to your
polyphil
it might sound obvious but it's it's
really surprising how many people don't
follow that
they make a function that implements
some functionality and then they're like
yeah use that function on any element
you want to fix
and they don't actually do that you
don't they don't actually do anything
except defining that function so to use
their polyfill
you have to actually add javascript code
get all these elements
yourself and apply that function to them
so afterwards when the time comes to
remove the polyfill
your code will break for example in this
case it calls
the init method of a details object when
the polyfill gets removed
this will throw an error there's no
details element defined
so that's that's not how polyfill should
work
also your polyfill will be applied in
many cases
in many different cases in many many
times the assumptions you make
will be wrong many times we tend to make
assumptions to make our job easier
but those assumptions don't really don't
really apply to every dog
any document and sometimes we know that
and we just choose to make these
assumptions
and some other times we just didn't
think of that
and if you actually have to make an
assumption for your polyfill to work
because maybe otherwise your code will
be 10 times as big that's fine
but you should at least know that you're
making this assumption
it should be a known unknown
so attributes and properties will change
there will be other scripts on that page
it won't be just yours
and those scripts will actually change
might actually change attributes and
properties
also new elements might get added maybe
via ajax or maybe they'll get created by
some other script but
the thing is if you're making a polyfill
for example for the html5 details
element
nothing guarantees that there will be as
many details elements when the document
is closed
as the ones that were there when it was
created
css can be very different from the one
you tried
you might have making sense you might
have been making
some assumptions and certain kind of
host css will break them
and there might not even be a dom that
might that might sound weird and you
might be thinking about
cases like node.js for example but
even in client-side javascript there's
not always a dom
for example in web workers your code
might need to run
in in a web worker if it's actually a
polyfill that applies
to something like that so you shouldn't
depend in
a dome being present and it might you
might be thinking now
why would i depend on a dome if my
polyfill has nothing to do with a dome
and i can it can even run in a in a web
worker for example if your polyfill
needs to resolve urls and get the
separate parts
one way is to parse the url yourself and
return the
and split it into parts like the host
name the path the query string and
everything
but another way would be to create a
dummy a element
and set its href to that url and then
get the properties from there
which will might sound quite clever at
the time but it will break when there's
no dom present
even though urls aren't breaking urls
into parts isn't something that
needs to depend on a dom and also
you shouldn't even depend on html it
might not be html your polyfill might
need to run in an svg document
or in an xml document and it should
still not break
of course some of these are edge cases
and some of these are edge cases
and maybe you want to make the decision
not to support them
because it will make your code base huge
and you will fall into the trap i felt
with the progress element
with the progress polyfill but you
should know that you're making these
assumptions and preferably you should
state them in the description of your
polyfill some people
know them and they won't spend time
debugging something
that isn't supposed to work in their
case
so the first thing uh responding to
attribute changes
this only applies to html polyfills
how can we actually do stuff when
attributes
change we have two tools for this first
is mutation events
which um which are events that get fired
when the dom tree changes when an
attribute gets removed when an attribute
changes when a new element gets added
the problem with those are they are
deprecated now and there's no
alternative
uh in the standard there's they're
preparing something
but it's not even in the spec there's
not even a spec yet and
of course no browser supports it so for
the time being
even though they're deprecated they're
the only thing we can use
and in old ie there's also this
horrible proprietary property change
event
which is kind of horrible like all
microsoft proprietary things but
sometimes it's the only way
and in polyfills it's the goal that
counts actually
filling in the gap because eventually it
will get removed polyfills
by nature are temporary so need
do what you got to do for example paul
backhouse created an amazing polyfill
for
css transforms and ie and he used that
and
that's actually how i learned about the
property change event
he's using that to convert
css transitions to the matrix filter
than
that ie uses and that allows us to make
css polyfills in ie that
they can even respond to changes which
is amazing we can't do that in other
browsers css polyfills are pain in the
ass
but in ie we can with that thing
so about mutation events
an example of a mutation event is dom
attribute modified and
that's one of the two you're going to
use more frequently it gets fired when
an attribute changes
and it we can get the
the old uh value from it the new value
and the attribute name
also mutation events bubble so we can
just
register an event handler in the
document and
uh then monitor all dome attribute
modified events
and if they're of the they're of the
kind that interests us
we do stuff if not we don't do anything
for example in this case
assume this is a part of a placeholder
polyfill
it tests if the node where the attribute
got changed
is an input node and then uh if the
attribute that got changed is the
placeholder attribute because then we
need to update the placeholder or if
it's a value because for example if we
didn't have a value and now we do
we need to uh we need to make the
placeholder vanish
so if that's the case we call our
function
in our polyfill and we update the node
we don't even need to pass
the new and the old values in this case
because the only thing
we need is the node in this case
the second thing that our polyfill
should try to be responsive
is properties things are a bit better in
this one because we have accessors
uh like you might have heard them as
getters and setters
and these are pretty standard we also
have on property chains for old ie
uh since i since old ie treats
properties as attributes that
event works in both and if your polyfill
is
only to fill in a firefox specific
functionality then you also have this
amazing
uh method uh that's supported only in
mozilla it's
it's proprietary but it's so amazing i
think
i think it should be added to the spec
and every every browser should implement
it
instead of accessors make you replace
the property
with an accessor get a getter in the
cellar just one of the two
object watch doesn't replace the
property it just watches it
and it fires a callback when it actually
changes which is exactly what we want in
polyfills
we don't really want to replace the
property it's a hack
but it's the only thing we have we
actually just want to monitor changes
watch changes and have something that's
the equivalent of an event
when the property when the property gets
changed
and that's the object watch is exactly
what we want
but it's only five for firefox so let's
focus a bit on accessors
the standard syntax is the one presented
here we use the define property method
in the
object in the object constructor
as you probably know all the new
ecmascript five functions and objects
are just added on the object constructor
instead of specific instances
even though it would be more convenient
so that they don't break backwards
compatibility
with when we make polyfills for them so
we have defined property it accepts a
get in the set
property in the in the parameter and
we make some call backs for them which
get fired when somebody attempts
to set that property so this property
essentially functions like a property
but actually
it's more like a function for example
in this case we define a getter in the
center for
a placeholder so when somebody uh tries
to
to get the placeholder uh value uh
through the getter
we actually invoke this function and
return the attribute value
because it's the same in this case in
some other cases you might want to do
some math because the getter
should return a number and the attribute
always returns strings
but in this case it's the same and when
it's set we invoke a function of our
polyfill that updates
the the placeholder and also to match
the native implementation of placeholder
we make this uh accessor numerable and
configurable which essentially mean
that a numeral is that when people use
this object on foreign loops
it will be present unlike some other
properties that don't get
enumerated and configurable means that
we should be able to replace it
with something else if we don't want
these accessories anymore
we i kind of disagree with it being
configurable but that's how the native
implementation works and like we said
you should follow the spec
you shouldn't break expectations so this
standard syntax of accessors is
supported by
ie8 firefox 4 chrome safari 4
5 and opera 12 and of course uh browsers
after those so what can we do with older
browsers some of them are really
oprah 12 isn't even released yet
and some of them are quite recent like
safari 5 is still kind of recent
there is an older syntax for gears and
setters which
works in many more browsers in many
older browsers
this was before ecmascript 5 was
published it was the first syntax we had
and i'm so glad we didn't actually do
that
and the ecmascript 5 way is so much
better
this actually only allows us to set
together in the center we can't set
we can't control whether it's
innumerable or whether it's configurable
or anything
but in this case it does what we want
and
it's a good fallback if you don't want
to have to deal with conditionals
about whether it's defined property
supported
is defined getter supported there's this
nice polyfill by ellie gray which
combines them
so you can actually use object define
property
and it will work even in those that
don't support it and only support that
kind of getters
so you actually can use a polyfill in
your polyfill it's so meta
a problem with ie8 is that even though
it supports
police support successors
it only supports them on dome elements
so if you're if you need to do something
else that's not
related with dom elements you're kind of
screwed
and also if that wasn't enough
old ie thinks that properties and
attributes are the same
so essentially let's remember the uh the
case i showed before
when the placeholder property gets uh
when when it
somebody tries to read the placeholder
property we call get attribute and we
return the attribute
but what if the placehold what if the
placeholder attribute is essentially the
same as the placeholder property like
what old ie thinks
we try to read the placeholder property
so
because attributes and properties are
the same for all day
so what does this gives uh give us it
gives us infinite recursion
it's so it's that horrible uh
it will we will actually make a script
that's really slow
and it will return in a stack overflow
also ie8 has this other problem with
defined property
if you try to use a numerable true it
will
throw an error which you can catch with
this
weird code and just uh
the solution to that is just to try to
apply the the accessor again
without the innumerable true just set
the numerable to false and try again
also the third thing we said is that
new elements might get added for example
through ajax through some script
so it's best if our polyfill doesn't
break with them and it's kind of simple
to account for them
if if we're modifying elements that are
already supported we can just add
the methods to the corresponding uh
prototype
uh you might you probably have heard
that modifying host objects is evil
but in this case uh you're not adding
property
you're not adding functions that weren't
there you're adding functions that
should be there
and everyone even no matter how
passionate they are about
not modifying host objects everyone
agrees that this is a legit case of
doing that
so you can even add a method to the
element prototype which is
for every element or to specific
prototypes for example
html input element so in that case it
will be automatically in every new
instance but if you can't do that for
example if you're making a polyfill for
a new
html5 element that doesn't have an
interface in browsers that don't support
it
you can you should use the the dom node
inserted mutation event
so that you do stuff when an element
gets added
that's uh of the type we're interested
in
of course that bubbles too so we can
follow the same approach as we did for
dome attribute modified
we just register a general handler and
we
check if we're actually interested uh in
that
in that particular element that was
added
also another thing you should keep in
mind is minimizing dependencies
for example libraries like jquery might
do your job quite easy
they might make your code a bit smaller
but
when you're making a polyfill that
requires jquery
you're actually requiring that everyone
who uses your polyfill
also includes a library that's like so
many kilobytes of code
especially if it's not gazeb so just to
add a small feature
some people will have to include a whole
library if they're not using it already
and especially in polyfills people want
to use
these latest these these new features
so that they break free from libraries
so you should you should try to avoid it
uh as much as possible unless it really
makes your job easier
unless your code your polyfill becomes
10 lines instead of 50 lines
but if it's like a difference like for
example i've seen polyfills that use
jquery
that were like 40 lines with jquery and
they were like 55 without jquery
is that really worth it
also when you're making a polyfill you
might be tempted
to support every possible browser to
support ie6 and ie7 and
uh because you want people to use it and
even in big projects that require uh
compatibility with my very old browsers
but sometimes this makes your code
huge and it's not really needed to be
that huge
for and sometimes you should you can use
the
internal methods that a browser can have
and take advantage of them and do what
you want
for example how many of you have heard
about much media
and what it does
well match media is a function uh it's a
global function
and it tests whether a document matches
a certain media query
so some browsers already support the
supported and we decided to make a
polyfill for those that don't
so how would you go with that polyfill
most people would probably try to parse
the the media query expression
and then check every condition
separately to see if it actually matches
but we don't need to do that it can be
much smaller but just taking advantage
of what the browser does with media
queries
because the browser already has this
functionality built in
so let's see how paul irish tackled this
problem
he creates a new element a new dev
sets sometimes some styles and an id
that's unlikely to collide with
another id and then it adds
a style element with a media query
inside that div
style elements can be anywhere so they
don't have to be in the head they can be
anywhere in the document so that's
pretty valid and it works and then it
depends
that element to the to the body
so let's think a bit about that
that stack has a media query and it
gives that l
that div a width of 42 pixels
what does that mean that if the media
query matches the document
that div will have a width of 42 pixels
if it doesn't it will have another width
so now to check if that media query
applies to this document
we only need to check if the offset
width of the diff of the div
is 42. so we actually took advantage
of the of the built-in browser
capabilities
for checking media queries and we
didn't need to pass anything
so after we get that value we clean up
after ourselves remove that div from the
body
and we return the result and because the
spec is kind of weird and it
requires us to return an object even
though
it might seem stupid and personally i
don't agree with that much
we have to follow the spec and return an
object literally like it's required
with the result and the media query
passed
another example of taking advantage of
the browser capabilities
is trying to implement outer html
ultra html used to be a microsoft
proprietary thing
but it's now in the html5 spec and
eventually all browsers will implement
it if they all don't already
so
some people might actually try to parse
the the outer html and do something with
that or extract the inner html portion
and then parse
pars the the the tag portion do
something like that but it's actually
much easier
you first check if the it's an xml
document by
tracking the xml version property of the
document
yeah that should be document not doc
and if if it's an xml document we can't
use inner html or anything like that so
we invoke the xml serializer and we
return we serialize
that node if it's not an html an xml
document which is the most common
case we create a new element that we
won't actually need but it will help us
in this case
and we append we clone this
the node we care about uh getting its
outer html
uh we passed the false parameters so
that we don't clone the contents as well
because think about it we don't need to
pass through to
to get the the outer html because we
just we can just get
in html from that node from the original
nodes
so the only thing we care about is
getting the html for the outer tag
so we just apply it to that dummy
element
then we replace we get the inner html of
the new element we replace
those uh that thing in the middle
and we add in html then
the inner html of the new element is
what we want it's the outer html that we
wanted we didn't need to do any parsing
we just used the browser capabilities
also this is sometimes an afterthought
but it shouldn't be
if you're making an html polyfill you
shouldn't you should keep accessibility
in mind
because native elements have uh
built-in area roles or they can be
focusable sometimes when the spec says
they should be focusable
or they support some certain keyboard
shortcuts like for example
a native slider supports being adjusted
by the the arrow keys
but so if you're actually implementing a
slider yourself
you should try to fake these things too
you should make it focusable by tab
index zero you should add some area
roles
yourself and some area attributes and
you should support these keyboard
shortcuts
i've seen so many sliders that can't be
adjusted with a keyboard it's so
annoying it's not even for people
with disabilities everyone uses the
keyboard
also like i said before css polyfills
are big pain in the ass
if if you're planning to start writing
polyfills
uh don't start from css everything is
hard with them
parsing is hard because you need to
parse the whole thing
because if you try to go through the css
object model
the browser will drop uh stuff it
doesn't understand
so there's no point in doing that you we
actually have to parse
the whole css style sheet also
implementation is hard
at least implementation that's done
unobtrusively
we almost always have to add extra
elements and extra stuff and
it's always so intrusive and reacting to
changes is practically impossible
i mean ie has this property change event
but other browsers don't
so we can't do anything about it they're
really hard and that's why we don't have
almost any css polyfills
most of them are just api wrappers like
i said before like functions that you
call to do something
but that's not really a polyfill
so after you've done you're done with
the creative part
the there comes the distribution part
because
you might be satisfied with your clever
code but you actually have
to let other people know and use it and
help the community like
like it helped you so the first part is
making a minified version
of the your script because uh
people will actually end up using that
but you also have to include the
original version
so that people can study it and see what
you did and how you didn't learn from
you
but you should also include a minified
version to be used for production
then upload it to github it's like the
common place these days for for open
source code
and the last step but one of the most
important is to add it to the polyfills
list
i think this is the most official
polyfills list we currently have it's
not perfect it's just a list
in the github wiki and we should
definitely do better
we need the polyfields database of some
sort but currently this is the most
complete thing we have
so you can just edit this it's a wiki
you
all everyone can edit it and add your
polyfill there
so now that this uh talk is nearing to
its end
let's talk a bit about the people that
have helped a lot in this field
first of all remy sharp is the guy that
actually thought
of the word polyphil and he's written
many
good politicians that are that people
actually use today
also paul iris has written loads of
polyfills
and he also maintains this list of
polyfills that i showed before
and i really admire ellie gray too he is
uh very young but he's really talented
he's
written so many polyfills and his
polyfills are always amazing
they're they're the least buggy
polyfills i've ever seen
and he knows all these things about the
inner workings of browsers that's
it's like crazy but it's not just these
guys
there are so many people that have
helped
by creating a polyfill or improving an
existing polyfill this list
is by no means exhaustive there are so
many more people
and these people have uh spent their
time
and energy just to help all of you
just to help the community i think they
deserve a loud clap for that
and you can be you can also do that you
can also help the community like
like it has helped you while uh
developing
something you can write something you
can uh
write a polyfill or help in by writing a
feature detection test
for something that's considered
undetectable
you can really make a difference and
that won't really help your
it will really help yourself and your
day-to-day development it will make your
code more future
proof but it will also help everyone
so go ahead and fully fill these gaps
thank you